garrett richards looks to stave off a
three-game sweep
richard you'll see a fastball 95-96
slider curveball change-up so here's
cedric mullins off to a nice start
multiple hits in both games he's four
for eight
let's hit the left center field and hit
pretty well and it's over the head of
verdugo short hops the wall
mullins
into second with a lead off double he is
now five for nine on the season third
game back for the colon cancer survivor
mancini right-handed batter steps in
that's hit well over the shortstop's
head into left field base hit mullins in
at third and trey mancini with a base
hit has runner on the corners here with
nobody down
first pitch swinging and bouncing it
past the drawn in infield for a base hit
santander mullen scores mancini at
second and the orioles are out of the
gate with three straight hits
in three games this year anthony
santander has three rbi singles
and he bounces one through the vacant
left side in the first to give the
orioles the game's opening run
michael franco two for eight couple of
rbis
riptar down the third baseline it's fair
into the corner
mancini's home
and so is santander a two-run double
for michael franco he broke the
scoreless tie drove in two yesterday now
adds two and the orioles go up three to
nothing we haven't really seen a lot of
them but when he gets into a fastball
count we have seen this he just rips it
you know it's not a horrible pitch but
he's looking for it so it becomes very
hittable and uh gonzalez can't catch it
just hit too hard this one does not hit
the cushion which happens very often on
balls down the line
and once it goes into the corner
anthony santeria can score all the way
from first
uh so bruce zimmerman uh this was going
to be his second major league start
first one last year was against tampa
bay a couple of home runs didn't throw
the ball particularly well then he came
in in relief in fenway pitch real well
one run in four innings
so you know fastball change up curveball
slider so he's got all the pitches
and he gets him oh great breaking ball
you get ahead you get the two strikes
you have a guy obviously alex verdugo as
you mentioned had a nice year in his
first year with the red sox and then you
make the perfect pitch
martinez skies one off the end of the
bat foul ground first base side trey
over to the stands and trey makes the
catch reaching over his left shoulder up
against the side rail
what a play by trey mancini who
said he was having some trouble
adjusting back to first base this year
but he made a nice lunging grab there
and ends a one two three first for bruce
zimmerman
cedric mullins double to lead off the
game
swing and a fly ball left hand side for
do go back at the track now coming in
he's gonna have to play this off the
wall it's off the monster near the
scoreboard cisco is up to third and
mullins will get into second his second
double of the game
so mullins
has two doubles and two at bats
in two innings
that's up high so mod castle works a
lead off walk
there's a shot in the left field base
hit for ruiz
and the orioles have the first two on
and that's wide for ball four they're
loaded with nobody out and richards who
had problems in the first two innings
for the red sox faces three in the third
and does not record an out
a new pitcher for the red sox is
left-hander josh taylor 3-0 to galvez
that's a four-pitch walk not even close
and the orioles lead is now four-nothing
so an rbi to galvez on the walk
two and two to hayes bags loaded nobody
down
hit hard down the left field line that's
a fair ball into the corner
one run is in here comes the second run
and stopping at third base is freddie
galvez so two rbis for austin hayes two
more in
orioles on top six to nothing here
in the third inning
the bases are loaded that's hit well
center field way back
no play here it's off the 379 sign one
run in two runs in mullen stops at third
and it's an rbi double two rbi double
for trey mancini as the orioles tack on
a couple more well we told you when the
game started he loves hitting here came
in as a 249 hitter with 22 rbis well
here comes three more
one down two in scoring position
gets away from vazquez
and mullins in the score to make it nine
nothing
ryan montcastled to the plate for the
second time this inning
first pitch swinging blinds it into
right field
base hit falls in front of renfro out
there mancini scores and the orioles
lead it 10-0
rbi for ryan modcastle alex corrid takes
the baseball and will have a pitching
change once more at fenway park this is
the major league debut however of
garrett whitlock he was
really impressive in spring training a
rule five guy
the 2-1 pitch is skyed into center field
and garrett whitlock is going to retire
the first hitter he faces in the big
league ski hernandez is there good stuff
for whitlock
christian oh for three on the season
turns on that a high fly ball deep to
left field that's up there and it's
going to be off the wall
and he is going to head into second at
the crack of the bat
it looked like maybe the first red sox
home run of the season
but he'll take the double
so here's [ __ ] says kiki hernandez
stings the line drive
and caught by valenka
tagging up is vasquez
and the red sox do get a run on the play
and they're on the scoreboard
bottom of the fourth 10-1 baltimore
jd martinez laying into one in a heidi
drive left center field up there
and that ball is gone and the red sox
hit their first home run
of 2021 jd martinez will touch them all
makes sense because one guy who has been
swinging the bat is jd
now he didn't wait around very long
there he got a fastball on the first
pitch right down the middle and he goes
right up the middle with it
straight away center field way out
well bruce zimmerman three outs away
from qualifying for maybe his first
major league win here comes one-two
breaking ball and a good one strike to
ball zimmerman goes off speed vasquez
goes with him
it's a little flare mancini with the
catch cream mancini on the outfield
grass two down yeah even if you're ahead
by eight runs you you play on the balls
of your feet anticipating it may be hit
to you and this is a jam shot inside out
you know he's away from the bag
excellent play
behind owen two
and he got him looking zimmerman with
two strikeouts in the inning four on the
game orioles lead at 10-2
so jd with five hits in the series
another shot by jd martinez down in the
corner
that's going to be a fair ball
hernandez turning around the throw home
won't get him and the run is in
and jd keeps on swinging it that makes
it 10 to 3.
another rocket by martinez that time
it's the breaking ball and right into
the barrel of the bat right down that
left field line
so it was a fastball he took for a home
run a breaking ball that time that he
pulls down in the corner and right now
he's swinging about very very well
and mullins has another base hit
base hit number five into the right
field corner cedric darting to second
and he's in with his third double of the
day three doubles two singles and a walk
take a bow cedric mullins man
well he's a very humble young man so he
won't do that but i'll tell you what he
ought to
santander there it is base hit into
right
drives in cedric mullins and the orioles
now lead at 11-3 orioles three outs away
from sweeping the red sox and it's tyler
wells time
big right-hander makes his major league
debut
0-1 hit hard but right to short and
that'll do it the force at second and
the orioles have swept the red sox an
11-3 final score today from fenway
way to go tyler wells his major league
appearance he gets to finish it off
bruce zimmerman the loyola blakefield
product
and uh former towson pitcher gets his
first major league win his family on
hand and boy what a day cedric mullins
had with five hits three of those
doubles and a walk reached all six times